well unlike a lot of people I've been
very surprised in the last couple years
at the enormity of the backlash against
emigrate illegal immigration believe in
just immigration period I that really
took me by surprise as it's taken
governor Spitzer by surprise and
President Bush by surprise and so on and
I personally think yes there's some you
know prejudice in in that reaction and
and it's obviously you know directed
primarily at Latinos so in a way that's
impossible to prove I think that the
black-white relation is more charged
than the Latino white relation there's
just there's a lot going on there but I
can't sort of scientifically prove that
I think it's a lot of things it it's
it's it's history it's it's mostly
history it's to some extent of just
looks based you know that if you're
white an African American looks
different er than a Latino butBut I
think it's it's mostly historical
you